and more than 100 academics were around
the world have signed a letter urging
the United Arab Emirates to release the
British student Mathew hedges the letter
highlights concerns over his
deteriorating mental health and claims
that the conditions in which he is being
kept violate internationally accepted
practices or the 31 year old Durham
University PhD student was detained at
Dubai Airport in May and his family say
he's been kept in solitary confinement
ever since when he saw her picture there
joining me now here in the studio is
Matthew's wife Daniela Tejada thank you
so much for coming in Daniela and just
explained why he was in UAE and and how
he came to be arrested so Matt went to
the UE after nearly three years of
embarking in this whole academic
research project for his PhD thesis and
he was going to the UAE for only two
weeks to sort of get some sources to
corroborate all of the information that
he had gathered through theory then we
were expecting him to come back after
two weeks of doing you know all the
interviews norther necessary gathering
of information that he needed and he
just didn't come back he got when was
the first that you heard that he'd been
detained it was actually on that day
nearly at that very time because his mom
who was in the UAE at the moment and at
the time went to drop him off in the
airport and that's where he got detained
and I got a call from her maybe 20
minutes half an hour later it just
obviously incredibly worried saying he's
being arrested he's being detained so it
kind of it took everyone by surprise
really was he aware that there were
risks to go into a country like UAE and
asking challenging questions people tend
to think that going to the Middle East
and doing research is a very risky
affair but I don't think anyone thought
like that that that would happen in a
country like the UAE who prides itself
in being such a Western open-minded
country definitely not mad he had been
living it he had lived in the UAE he had
visited on and off since 2008
and he had studied it so well that he
really knew it like the back of his hand
his colleagues and friends just could
not believe what was going on either and
they are all kind of specialists in that
area so I don't think anyone could have
predicted that this would kind of take
this unexpected turn of events what is
the procedure what is the process that
you know how to go through it's been
very unclear for the past nearly six
months of try to make all sorts of
inquiries as to what the process is and
what to expect from it
however only until last week or the past
ten days have we started getting some
answers about what the process is and
what's going to happen
he was press charges formerly we found
out about this through the news which
was completely devastating really and
now we're just trying to figure out what
happens kind of on a day to day basis he
has a hearing coming up this Wednesday I
have been told that in this hearing it's
just going to be him and his
court-appointed lawyer presenting the
defense but because everything's being
so unpredictable I couldn't put my hands
on fire for and what help have the
British authorities been while whilst
he's been in health they're being
heavily involved as matter of fact I got
notified that the Foreign Secretary had
made a couple of representations but in
terms of how effective those were
presentations have been not just the
Foreign Secretary's but all of the ones
that came before I think it's rather
debatable I was told that it was all
about his welfare and that's all the
focus at the Foreign Office good plays
although he is an innocent man being
unjustly held but even in that sense he
wasn't even granted those like that
rightful treatment that he deserved I
mean he was in solitary confinement for
nearly six months and he hasn't changed
so they were accusing him of spying as
that
yes it's actually gathering information
to share with a foreign agency which
it's completely outrageous he his
research from top to bottom and I pretty
much have read every single one of his
emails and I could not find any
compromising information so I just I
think it's probably gone out of their
hands and now they're trying to find
something to charge him with well he was
gathering information but he's got it
for his PhD oh yeah yeah what helped a
baby they have been helpful they have
been supporting me all throughout
particularly his supervisor professor
Clive Jones has been amazing the
University are slowly working on kind of
releasing a formal statement to come and
Matt's defense but they have been
fantastic they issued a letter of Good
Standing to the UAE courts saying you
know matt was actually engaging a
legitimate research please set him free
because he is not guilty of what he's
been accused of but yeah they are
collaborating and they're also working
with other universities to kind of get
Mac home and what's your contact with
with Matthew been liking it and how is
he coping it's a bit of ups and downs
so some weeks he he feels a bit calmer
some others he's very distressed most of
the times he's been under a lot of
stress he suffers from depression
anxiety and naturally the conditions
that he's being kept in have had a
horrible toll on his state of being but
slowly but steadily I'm hoping that the
treatment towards him will improve and
most definitely that he'll be released
to get the proper treatment that he
deserves which is from an expert here in
the UK and his family and friends and
you would be married for a year and a
half yeah together very much
no we've unfortunately been only be
we've only been able to spend between
four and five months together we got
married last year in January but I had
to leave the country soon
to process my visa papers and then we
were finally starting to get our lives
together and this happened so it hasn't
really been the ideal start to a
marriage